[Music]
get the wear clothes on I do I mean how
do you have muscle in there I have no
muscle there
you know what I've been working out for
30 years straight since I'm 44 started
working out when I was 14 I got this
funny thing I got electrocuted when I
was 2 years old it's a sad story stories
funny already
I put an extension cord in my mouth it
was so sad it was really - according
your mascara here getting put in since
you caught my mouth POW I was
electrocuted my mother is like oh my god
you survived you're a special baby I
thought I had superpowers I'm not
kidding you I was reading comic books I
was like that's how I got spider-man and
I said superhero origin you're
describing total superhero origin and I
thought I had superpowers so I was a kid
I was like all right when I turned 14
and I started lifting weights I always
thought I had that and I never stopped
and you know it's funny and then my wife
tells me he's like you're just a regular
man superhero at the age of Chewie puts
an extension cord in his mouth gets
shocked and can wiggle his Mane movie
no I got a TRO Terry now you caught you
gave yourself the nickname Terry the
amusement park cruise why the amusement
park because I am funny and scary at the
same time look at those rides it's fine
inviting that that one clown is sitting
there looking at you yeah that is my act
that's been my act for years you're
funny but you're scary at the same time
so it's a thin line you know what I mean
it's like I used to do in high school I
used to turnip even better what what
you're talking to me man
are you talking to me and they go
[Applause]
just like that turn it on and off it
works on Expendables it worked in white
chicks
it goes all this way you know it just
kind of goes from one day when I get mad
people just laugh that's the thing it's
you can get them to laugh but then you
can probably switch it around and get
really intense but when I get intense
and I'm like just think oh what a silly
fool
you only Joe Pesci should do an act
together yeah you know what I always
realized that I had that power it's kind
of a cool cool thing because playing in
the NFL you needed it you know it's kind
of like if you have two good parents and
a nice life you ain't going in NFL okay
it takes a lot of pain you know
channeling thought you got a channel it
and you got it but then in the locker
room I was the funny guy that was the
thing let me ask you a question you have
is it for daughters or dogs I'm curious
about something you can be very
intimidating we've all seen you do it
and you can get a scary look in your eye
I can imagine someone dating one of your
daughters and going to the house and you
answer the door
is that going to be an issue let me tell
you something it's already no no really
it's already been an issue and I'm
telling you I tried it and then I got
famous getting famous changes the game
because then I think they want to get
hit they're like hit maybe they they're
limping out of the door my hey man I hit
you I was a 16 million dollar city and
then your daughter she it doesn't work
because they always tell their secrets
they're like oh he's nothing he's using
that little trick it's the little trick
where he acts me and he'll laugh a
little bit later yeah that's the trick
and I my aha this is gave away are all
my secrets right because you should be
able to I would think really scare the
crap out of somebody you know and then
you know they actually have to my
daughters have to go off by their own
and they do whatever they want to do
anyway so it doesn't work